ladies and gentlemen we have made it to
the final episode of superman and lois
last sons of krypton who are they
referring to am i right guys this show
has been a hell of a journey not rich
say goodbye every episode has been
either really good too freaking
phenomenal
somewhere in that range can't imagine
this now it's gonna be any less ask you
guys up front what do you think about
this finale what are your hopes for
season two and if you want us to cover
season two hit that like button and also
subscribe and click the notification
bell so we got other stuff we covered as
always full length watch as long as we
sync up with the time coder over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there as well lastly for thm
jindal thanks for editing all these
highlights for us bud i'm sure you're
just as sentimental as we are
all right don't cry for them let's watch
this
[Music]
you're going to fail you're a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ]
boss
i will
[Music]
oh lana i think i have some slings in
the truck okay let's just take it easy
ready
good thing you're still in town kyle
yeah
john why would he take jordan
oh
no oh
and you
son of callum
will help me do it
[Music]
call batman
you wouldn't be much more help
call barry allen tell me where edge took
jordan well i don't know
where is my son your son
i'm sure he's long gone by now
what have you done
the world's best investigative
journalist can't figure that out
hey
we're gonna find them really because you
have no idea what's coming next even
superman won't be able to stop it time's
up famous last words
my nipples have been hard this whole
episode so far
that's how we can go
but we can stay in help we stay and help
can we help
[Applause]
we're firefighters and we're never
moving
wow he's scouring the whole planet right
now
he's gonna like crash headlong into
morgan edge
oh it's gonna be like the beginning
[Music]
[Laughter]
edge wasn't caught was he
at one point
holy [ __ ]
oh man
it's like
the reapers here yeah
to watch them tear each other apart
are you okay are you hurt
no no no no i don't think so
what happened
edge grabbed me and then next thing i
remember
[Music]
tom cavanaugh directed this episode no
way i was eradicated
and then there's that yeah
the plot
[Laughter]
got distracted there be a child who
possesses the untapped power of
plutonium or the easily manipulated mind
of a human
now i will move both into proper
greatness oh this is so creepy
oh
oh
boy
i sacrificed my only son to save our
people and you don't even have the
strength to strike
yours oh
god no no
whoa whoa whoa
come on
yeah
no
oh
that look on his face
what's not in his hand
he's
no
how do you
we need to evacuate smallville everyone
they need to get as far away from here
as possible as quickly as possible
twitter mass email
where can where can they go that safe
yeah they want to hear from mr mac yeah
whatever we need to do
i guess you got to do something
good thing kyle has a huge social media
phone
when i used one of my solar flares on
him it made it them then we need as much
as we can get
i have some solar weapons left
it might do the trick plus there's the
ones you took okay look so um joined the
fight jonathan
finally getting to work well uncle john
when zod was in your mind how tough was
he to overcome nearly impossible but it
was possible prepare for when we find
him because we will or he'll find us
i don't even know what you want to do
when that happens
family therapist
you and john henry can take down edge
and jonathan and i will save jordan
mark you and i brought the boys into the
superhero world and i wasn't sure it was
the right thing to do but i have seen
how capable they've become
they're strong like their father
like their mother we are superman and
lois
here's all the weapons i borrowed
god damn
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
hammer time red solar tech plus the
hammer's kinetic force should pierce the
eradicator's energy field and dissipate
his power reserves the hammer needs to
gain maximum force which means a long
throw an edge needs to be locked down
dead center of the [ __ ]
right because that's totally doable i
mean he only has like six other badass
kryptonian dudes with him look those are
terrible odds this is really the plan
you'll be guarding your mother while she
finds your way into one of jordan's
memories that was that thing it's a
restored weapon of thaddeus kilgraves
who all you need to know is you don't
use this unless you have to
oh my goodness
so much x-crypt tonight
so terrible hugs
sure
full-on partners
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
stuntman
oh
oh
[Music]
it won't be all for long
create the world of the dream
oh no
wow
you'll never get to him he's been buried
deep in his subconscious i'll find him
you don't even know where to look
i know my son
no man
it's mind games literally
oh no
jordan
mom did it
she didn't
jordan
[Music]
whoa
hey now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's mom i need you to hear me
you find that strength to come back to
us i know you can do it baby
[Music]
i'm proud of you
[Music]
[Music]
we did it
[Laughter]
on my mark
you don't have much time
no
[Music]
oh wow whoa
oh
[Music]
oh
come on
nailed it
now
i'm gonna be right back i promise
nice timing
my best
ah he didn't say you're late
all i wanted was a family car
you had
we it brothers
i could have had family man
he could have had him right there the
whole time
i've seen more than my share of
disasters
where his uniform
i want the world to know the truth
morgan edge
is not from this planet
he in fact is from krypton morgan
address kryptonian
no
yes
and is it still possible for these
kryptonian mines to be implanted in
humans
not anymore makes me wonder are you at
all worried that this would make people
afraid of kryptonians
you mean me
that's not something i will ever be able
to control
smallville will be stronger than it has
ever been before
there you go kyle
hey
you know
i met my best friend here oh is that so
whoa injustice
[Laughter]
don't ever better get supes you just
can't get a win can you qb2
oh
i wouldn't be so sure
[Music]
nice
let's go on a little fact-finding
mission plea to not sell the gazette
lois the lawyer is drawing up the
paperwork tomorrow which is why i want
to buy half of it from you today
what do you think you want to be
partners with me
yeah
are you freaking kidding me right now
yesterday
[Music]
oh
keeping the ashes
this tree always gets the best light
this time of day not your dad would like
it here
is everything okay john your mood
appears rather pensive
you got everything packed up uh yeah
john not now an enormous vessel has just
linked to your lawsuit cpu and is
approaching at a dangerously high
velocity
whoa what
what the [ __ ] is happening
oh oh oh oh no don't
is it
no it's to be
it can't be is it her it is her it is
her
he could stay
now lois can have two families oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
oh there's gonna be a lot of explaining
to do
that's a lot darker than i thought it
would be
[Music]
all right
congratulations to that man that was
[ __ ] amazing a plus and they nailed
the season beginning to end and jordan
did not murder anyone on the football
team don't you ever think i forgot about
those words
we should never have doubted him never
have doubted
the second that he cannot handle the
football team
next season has even more football
football
you always got to set up a season two
right
i was actually halfway hoping they
wouldn't
because i was like man this is a perfect
story wrap up yeah there's like a
perfect i mean you gotta set up a season
two
they're already green lit for season two
so they got green the first season two
like many many many episodes ago
i think it was like a rare in the pilot
premiere or something like that in our
literally people like this
so it's not a qualm i liked i liked what
they teased i i really did it's not it's
not a real criticism there's that a
little part of me that's going ah i kind
of wish
they didn't could just leave off on the
on the yeah wrap up and leave off on
just the afterglow of everything that
has culminated and been laid to rest
but it's more than just a setup though
to give it to be fair because
it's also his daughter returning
yeah so it's the conclusion of that one
it's something that could lead to a lot
of different things yeah like just one
specific oh here's the story of the next
season you know yeah it would have been
a little bit fine with just the funeral
but it also still wraps up that part of
the storyline yeah right when it crashed
i was like it's gotta be it's gotta be
natalie it's gotta be her right it is
totally is i totally forgot i thought
she was looking at them i was like oh
yeah that's right she hates that guy she
hates superman and her mom is dead yeah
yeah yeah she looks like she's seen a
ghost
so much is going on in that one one
little exchange of looks yeah absolutely
but in terms of uh
then the reason the only reason why i'm
saying i wish that is because
this is one of the best season finales
i've ever seen of any show
uh hands down they really told a
complete story here
everything wrapped up in that whole
little monologue that clark was giving
when he was unveiling the truth you know
you have so much dealing with like how
much of the that's been such a back and
forth debate with this show
already with lois the dod and the
integrity of journalism integrity of the
public knowing the truth
and how much should they know so clark
unveiling the whole truth
um
is is like the wrap up to that they know
everything everything about all the
chaos that occurred and all the
unfortunate situations has made them
stronger and smallville
has made them and smallville stronger
and
um
you know like the the growth of
everything all around
on just a great cinematic level like i'm
looking at this going damn this just
looks so cool in a theater like
how how crazy is that like like the
whole thing with the town falling apart
and them just trying to evacuate and
they're not able to evacuate like that
looked so good that's like the beginning
of a quiet place too yeah like it was so
good you know i really feel like you're
in the midst of a disaster and they got
me worried you know like any time they
would like get out of the car when kyle
runs off to go help people like i i
really bought the sense of
this could all end right here you know
yeah and then [ __ ] jonathan keeps
losing this whole season he finally gets
he gets a win at the end this chance
with uh
with information yes i'm on board with
her now just because that little
exchange i was just happy for him
because he looked happy yeah yeah that
was that was a really nice wrap up there
and you know jonathan
who uh no jordan who keeps having to
deal with um this insecurity of not
being good enough and not being strong
enough and i you know
i it was cool that the technology thing
came into play
again
uh and i love that they set that up this
just seems like such a wonderfully
composed season because that i would
hate if that was introduced in this
episode and i was like well that's
convenient you know that they have this
technology where they can hop into the
mind
and so
they tease they use that in another
episode where it was you know explaining
showing the origin of superman and lois
and then there was such tragedy that
came with that
because there's morgan edge manipulating
him
and then here they use that same thing
and it comes back around to save
jordan
which is just so neat
you know like it's
it's beautiful i i think i was just like
either on the verge of crying or crying
this whole time i was watching this
because i was so
i was so moved by everything like
the heroic nature the peril and it never
got corny you know
it never it never got cheesy
and the action imbued when they're
finding all the kryptonians and then
john and um well steele and clark having
a fight together
and even freaking you know
john getting his uh
when he like freaking
successfully uh you know uh thor's uh
yeah
infinity wars uh morgan edge in that
moment and he did it like he the thing
he felt he was failing to do on his
planet he he did it here he saved the
day his exact fears
ever like i just i'm so impressed with
the show
kal-el was tempted at times just because
zod infiltrated his own soul
but then they saved the day and then
like what what john feared this whole
time of what could happen with this
earth and kryptonians rising it was just
on that on the brink of all that
happening and then his whole motive was
he has to save this earth because he
couldn't do what he wanted to do on his
planet and he gets to do it here
and you don't really see
what i love is that the story telling
of where these arcs and journeys are
going are the furthest thing from
obvious you know
like i really really loved i love that
so much who is calling me at this time i
can't talk right now aaron alexander
jesus christ he just watched the finale
and he wants to join in the conversation
leave me alone i'm in the middle of
talking about this show
yeah it was it was uh
they did everything the freaking even
even right down to the dad
you know like
really committing to his family leaving
the dod to commit to his family wow they
they're
they're wrapping up storylines like all
around and not leaving anything
and anything undone like it feels like
they completed a whole story here yeah
and they're setting you up for a sequel
yeah you know yeah well and even lois
coming around and like you know putting
down to buy half of the gazette and like
really you know teaming up with oh god
i'm blanking on her name but you know
the woman from the paper and everything
and like even that you know has been
such a struggle over the season to
really get them both on the same page
and there's been all the you know
basically attention around yeah
journalistic integrity and what
information gets to who and so i thought
that was also appropriate that now that
you know she doesn't have to deal with
having her dad in the dod they really
can go after you know the most honest
and the most hard-hitting you know
stories that they can and then you know
that enhances
all the different aspects of heroism and
i loved what this episode did with that
because you know it's like that's part
of it is getting people the truth is a
big part of it and that was hindered
throughout the season that was a source
of friction and now they can move
forward hopefully unencumbered in that
way and the people on the ground like
kyle even though he's been you know
shunned from his people like when the
emergency happens he's in there trying
to help people out and even the citizens
of smallville everybody at least after
all this unrest and after all this anger
directed
directed at the dod when [ __ ] actually
starts going down you know you you i
like that they took time for that you
just see all the people scrambling
around at least trying to you know find
shelter for each other and at least look
out for each other when it really counts
and then everything yeah like john henry
irons and and clark having to like it
being crucial that they work together to
ultimately bring down morgan edge like
yeah there's so many really nice
dovetails and it feels like yeah an
expertly composed season because there's
so many
emotional storylines running alongside
the action that intertwine and that
really feel yeah like they were
expertly mapped before any of this was
shot and i mean they added episodes in
progress of the season so i know it
wasn't that way but they helped it helps
it all breathe it really does this does
not feel rushed no like this was
100 percent solid they they nailed it
yeah they nailed this the season and
they nailed their finale like it was
i'm so surprised but i took this one
very seriously yeah you know they
reached such
action-oriented heights like there are
some really you know huge action moments
and it is the desperate last stand of
you know where we're gonna become
cryptiformed if this doesn't go right
and then you have also just all of these
emotional heights too or yeah i was
you know you saw it in the reaction i
was crying most of the time
that was
if there's one little criticism i have
towards the season
is uh whenever you know someone was
eradicated whenever there was another
kryptonium brought to life
it constantly had this back and forth of
me of
oh [ __ ] that's crazy even here when they
they say the defense counsel is here
but then it seems like taking them out
was never as difficult as you would
think yeah like fighting them is never
as difficult as you'd think yeah soup
seemed to pretty to handle it pretty
well
all things considered and then even like
john henry irons
uh when when they start fighting them
you know i'm like how is he able to like
in this episode how is he able to like
get a swing ready to hit them when
they're moving at like lightning speed
you know yeah you know
this is my
one little criticism about it is
i know there's probably justifications
as to why i get their eyes experienced
or not as cool the hosts they're not
from smallville so it won't last as long
or whatever yeah there's a whole bunch
of of reasoning to it it
i just did notice it was a constant back
and forth of oh [ __ ] and okay they got
it yeah yeah it's an immediate stakes
razor but not an actual stakes yeah
yeah and they're like we got the defense
counsel all right so these guys should
be like the ultimate like hardest to
[ __ ] take out i mean they were
putting up a hell of a fight and what i
thought was great about um john henry
irons and him teaming up
for one having to find multiple
kryptonians is that they both seem
necessary like
to
backpedal a little bit on what i just
said i would say that
what really
enhanced it
is i don't think superman could have
done it alone yeah absolutely like he
really needed help at to say the least
they both seem necessary
like that shot when when they're all
just piling on him
he can't get rid of them and then he
just that perfect throw that depletes
his whole system that just knocks them
all away yeah like that was like a great
moment and it really showed the
necessity of both and that superman
probably
would have lost yeah yeah even with uh
morgan edge you know he'd like superman
he's got to go in there and hold him so
that john can hit that can get that
target shot and it's like if they hadn't
had each other
just this might not have worked at all
yeah yeah yeah and so it it really does
also kind of enhance the multiverse
quality not that that's like the most
important part of the season or anything
but you know it's like john comes from a
world where
yeah
they failed like they didn't have the
right circumstances in order to thwart
this attack and here they did
and you really feel especially through
him i i think you really feel the
catharsis of that true um yeah it's
really beautiful oh yeah in every which
way that you do
and even right down to like
lana and kyle and uh sarah being here
like
kyle's
you know this is
what i thought they did so well was that
they were there was so much problems
that everyone has and the problems keep
escalating and what they what they're
doing is they're uprooting all that like
in order to it's kind of like
it's kind of like when you want to get
clean if you're an addict you know you
got to go through the withdrawal so it's
going to be ugly it's going to be messy
and it's going to be emotional and it's
going to be hard but in the end
it's bright and it's hopeful and that's
kind of what i thought they did here was
like it just everything was just
crumbling and you're just uprooting all
this [ __ ]
like throughout the whole season it just
keeps getting worse and right down to
smallville just up in chaos when they're
like get this dod out of here what's
going on and then morgan ed showing up
and then kyle losing his job then
wanting to leave but then through that
chaos kyle gets to come out on there as
a hero
and uh have a real redemption moment of
saving someone
and everyone saw it and everyone was
like okay you can come back we all love
you yeah
yeah yeah we'll come back to your
partner
all right you're cool sorry about all
the really nasty stuff i said and did
back when i hated you
[Laughter]
didn't mean any of that buddy you can
all come here and then i thought jordan
would tell sarah
yeah i really thought he did i feel like
it's fine if he does i know there's all
the problems i've seen smallville i've
seen
all the shows where you don't tell the
person yeah you know i i i know everyone
knows
i i think this show has a bit of an
exception to it though where i think it
would be all
i think it'd be all right
like i don't know what the harm would
really be in her knowing and especially
after everything they've gone through
you know well in a way i mean you know
because
not that the show begs this but one
thing people have often said of the show
is like you know it doesn't spend a
bunch of time going here's how superman
and lois met and sort of established you
know the relationship they have now but
i feel like you could kind of do an
alternate version of that through
jonathan
jordan and sarah and show the you know
the the interesting ups and downs of her
having to
you know
carry this information and keep it
secret and you know what that does to a
relationship especially when you're that
young i guess you probably shouldn't say
something unless you know you're going
to spend the rest of your life with this
person
that's also fair they're in high school
yeah
because clark
in this timeline clark did not tell her
until he was ready to propose yeah um
which sounds like a solid reason
to wait yeah or if they have a nasty
breakup
i asked her to move in with me and then
i revealed my powers
like what if what if it gets ugly and
then she starts snitching on him you
know you never know what horrible things
she might do that's true what if he
snaps and kills her
yeah then
then people would know where to look for
the killer
so you better also be mindful if you're
trying to turn evil sometimes yeah you
know like there's there's uh i there's
there's reasons um
but that's a debate
yeah it's always an understandable
debate
you know just as an audience member who
likes sarah a lot i'm like i think you
just tell her
and i thought jonathan might for a hot
second there but you know they just left
it on a on a pause
yeah yeah
i mean he can't no jonathan can't can't
tell her but um jordan could i did love
that scene when jonathan uh is embracing
his brother
yeah and holding each other up in the
air like that
and uh yeah letting love win i really
love that i love that in the c double
and all the cw shows that's often my
favorite quality
is
love wins
well yeah and to see i don't know like
it's it's refreshing almost to have it
just be a brother telling his brother i
love you you're like there's something
just it seems i don't know a little more
out of the ordinary about that and a
little more striking or at least in the
moment the way it was hewn here it was
very striking well yeah i mean it's it
was like the final nail in the coffin to
put away
the dad the evil dad and him oh yeah
zetaro
he has his name yeah
because yeah it was everything was
working but once he said that then
something like that was it yeah that was
the final moment and that's a great
little mirror too because that's you
know part of the wedge between morgan
edge and clark is uh you know
he just wanted a brother
but he didn't you know have the
wherewithal to like see a different way
that that could work and so i love that
yeah it's like you know jordan's got the
best brother ever right here
yeah you know so much of the themes of
this were about like
learning to forgive letting the past go
um learning from the past mistakes
that's been so much of that that was
really right down to
you know the hardship of having to
depend so much on joerl
that uh the hologram the ai essentially
of jorel and then now he's gone and
having to say goodbye and i like how
they had like an actual like little
funeral for him it wasn't just uh
yeah it wasn't just let me pick up the
pieces and buy you know i was like no
he's real i love the way the show
treated that that this
he was raised by him it wasn't just a
hologram it wasn't just an ai that was
his father and the fortress is you know
a home of sorts too of course
um
so yeah i thought like having a funeral
was very appropriate and surprising i
didn't expect a funeral
for that you know yeah uh very moving
stuff so yeah having to
having to grow from the loss that's what
i mean so much of this i think they just
did such an excellent job i am i'm so
impressed with this yeah in like every
way it's like everything's there are
more people watching this
now yes like everything is is the right
size and scale to suit the sci-fi but
also like a very down to earth in a lot
of ways emotional story like it just
feels like you know it's just good
storytelling well everything i was also
saying i think is complemented with
morgan edge because that last little
moment like morgan edge has kind of just
been a terminator the past few episodes
but that moment i was like i just wanted
a family and kyle you know it's it's so
funny because when kell
says
uh you you did i remember you had your
brother
you're like it just suddenly just like
even for me i'm like okay damn he's
right you could have just
he like your dad was a dick to you man
and he just kept messing with you yeah
and you'd be like i want family and it's
like oh you you still could have had
what you wanted if you just didn't go
down this path and you just
were with kell yeah then you could have
had what you it was what you were
searching for was there if you could
have crawled out yeah
yeah yeah you had it the whole time and
i'm like even for me i'm like oh damn
he's clark's right he
he had it the whole time and he just
didn't seize the opportunity because he
was so determined for this other thing
um when he when he had the family right
there before him
and think of how things might be if they
had grown up together and the world had
two champions of krypton or something
yeah or if he had just stopped the way
through and realized
oh you know what i don't need to follow
through with my father's plan i can just
kind of team up with little soups here
and then we can do our own yeah we can
meet the nice humans but yeah cause
there's because there's the themes of
nature versus nurture between the two of
them as well
i am interested i mean i'm glad the
first season is solid cw often has a
reputation of botching their later
seasons
uh you know it's usually like the first
couple are always great not for every
show
uh sometimes the first seasons are rocky
and in the second season when it gets
great
there's a great first season i can't see
it going down repetitive territory uh
with having the daughter around i can
see like i think you do some great stuff
with it but i could say really botch it
i could also see how you can have morgan
edge be repetitive
or uh you know predictable like you know
an uneasy alliance but he still wants to
kind of do the same thing he did before
i know i could see some [ __ ] being
repetitive
the woman's in prison the assistant and
so
yeah i mean i don't want to get too far
down that rabbit hole of what could go
wrong
right now i just want to appreciate the
season and for what this season is and
for what this finale is they nailed it i
thought they absolutely killed it in
every fashion and
dare i say it i think it's the probably
the strongest show we've seen all year
probably i think it's i think it's the
strongest one out of any show we've
reacted to on youtube this is probably
like the
the best composed one it really yeah
composed is a great word for it because
it really does feel poised and composed
and graceful and and not to say that the
other shows we've seen don't in some way
but this one especially
feels like it was really well thought
out and really
uh just you know hammered and folded you
know and really scanned for emotional
resonance above all else you know
that's headed out of one division
it's a little toss-up
between the two yeah um
yeah so i'm gonna have to go back and
re-watch both
and then make a decision it's different
yeah because we have to compare them
yeah you got them man important they're
the exact same show there's jesus
that video is they're in the same genre
of superhero show so that means they're
the they're the exact same show
and they're trying to do the same stuff
yeah
it's like curb your enthusiasm is a
comedy so
is
friends they're the same the same show
in fact it's all the same jokes
different cast
you know how it goes
all the shows are the same all the shows
are they're all the same every genre is
just the same every genre means it's the
same show
all right guys what do you think about
the finale leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button what are your hopes for
season two last but not least
got a shout out anissa oliva
she gave
greggy
this shirt look at that
love this shirt that's a great shirt
it's a fantastic shirt anissa
you know if i was an eradicator
i would eradicate you
i would
be like
let me make you
one of me
that would be a wonderful thing to have
happen i think
and then you would go evil voice i put
evil greg in you
i am
craig i am here to restore balance
there's good lip sync in this episode i
want to see you guys try it now i feel
like that's how it would go
and then craig would finally eliminate
my greatest threat jon humphrey that's
right man he'd finally take him out and
then anissa would go back and forth from
red eyes to normalized what have i done
i have to do it more
i don't want to but i have to
[Laughter]
my bloodlust is kicking in i talked with
you recently anissa you know how much i
miss you and how much i'm thinking about
you and you're an amazing amazing soul
amazing spirit
and i will eradicate you that's also
yeah
i will change all that's great about you
for my own selfish purposes
yeah yeah it'll be better that way
all right anisa well i love you i'll
talk with you soon okay dear
see you ready to kill
[Music]